demain il est sans aucun doute le
sénégal est le plus connu au monde
l'afrique et son berceau
elle a nourri sa musique qui s'est
enrichi de mille influences
aujourd'hui ce pack de la pop
internationale jette un pont entre dakar
et kingston en consacrant son 26e album
reggae voici maintenant l'invité des
cinq dernières minutes et s'est invitée
c'est youssou ndour bonjour on est
vraiment ravis toujours de vous recevoir
ici celui de vaud troisième fois qu on
vous reçoit mais là c'est vraiment pour
un album étape j'ai envie de dire
l'album s'appelle de dakar à kingston
dakar kingston il est publié chez
universal vous est ce soir en concert à
l'olympia
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ce
moment précis ve de votre carrière vous
avez envie d'aller vers le reggae mais
d'abord je j'ai grandi avec le reggae
comme beaucoup d'africains et
effectivement il y en a qui l'incarnent
il ya dans qui n'incarne pas je respecte
la philosophie mais je ne l'incarné pas
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on n'évolue
pas avec cette musique et quand j'étais
très jeune
mon oncle nous faisait écouter bob
marley jimmy cliff et autres et donc
j'ai grandi avec cette musique un moment
l'année dernière donc nous avons pensé
célébrer des grands de la diaspora noire
qui ont marqué l'histoire
on parle aujourd'hui des deux
cinquantenaires des indépendances et
tout donc beaucoup de gens ont pensé que
j'avais
je devais créer cette prêt d'union entre
la jamaïque bob marley et l'afrique
c'est quelqu'un de très important pour
vous et vous lui consacrez en titre dans
l'album bob marley est manifestement
vous avez une admiration pour cet homme
extrêmement forte en afrique on rend
hommage
on a on a ses habitudes là de deux
marques est vraiment le parcours de
quelqu'un et bob marley effectivement je
les adore musicalement mais au niveau
aussi de son contenu c'est quelqu'un qui
parlait beaucoup de l'unité africaine
équipe qui était vraiment concernées par
l'afrique et je crois que son message
doit encore continuer à servir pour bhl
des causes de justice et puis comme vous
il a réussi un truc incroyable est
reconnue partout dans le monde tout en
restant chez lui c'est ce que vous
faites vous vous restez au sénégal vous
êtes connu partout dans le monde n'irait
fait la même chose
oui moi je suis toujours basée au
sénégal je pense que bobo parler avec
son succès quelqu'un comme moi je me
suis dit bien pourquoi pas moi parce que
bon il vient d'un pays du tiers-monde et
il a touché tout le monde et tous les
jeunes de se disait pourquoi pas moi on
me l'a fait l'album est très réussi
vraiment c'est il ya comme vous le dites
dans le titre un pont entre dakar et
kingston et vous êtes entouré des plus
proches de marley qui ont collaboré avec
vous pour cet album on a on a travaillé
surtout avec tyrone downie qui est le
producteur de cet album qui nous a
tellement bien reçus en jamais qu'à
kingson j'espère que j'allais bien
dessus à dakar en tout cas c'était lui
de pont et ouais c'était fantastique
avec la famille de bob marley ses amis
j'ai écouté tellement d'anecdotes
tellement de on a touché des objets
discuter sur des périodes et où c'était
vraiment très fort et je tiens à
remercier theron qui s'est impliqué
beaucoup plus même que seulement
réalisateur c'est un grand frère vous
jouez ce soir à l'olympia c'est un
concert important pour vous et pour les
français parce qu'on s'est beaucoup ici
en france
est-ce que vous irez jouer à kingston
oui c'est mon rêve je crois que il y
avait un journal local qui avait signalé
mon arrivée là bas
et moi je les ai répondu en disant que
bon j'aimerais bien que vous mais vite
m'éviter et je pense que cet album appel
je l'a jamais que de toutes les manières
je suis prêt je pense que ce serait
honteux ils vont vous invitez ça c'est
si oui j'étais étonné en préparant cette
interview parce que vous qui avez
toujours mais alors mille projets vous
participez à plein de choses et monter
des studios à dakar fait travailler des
jeunes faisait vous en mettra votre 26e
album et là vous dites que vous n'avez
pas d'idées pour un autre projet musical
qu'est ce qui vous arrive du temps c'est
étonnant surtout surtout on serait déçus
non non non je crois que je crois que
bon généralement avec les artistes et
quand justin album sort on a une
nouvelle idée on essaie de mais gégé
rien ça veut dire quoi
peut-être que cet album là me plaît
énormément c'est à l'aubade la vie
devant et oui je vais pousser ou de pubs
les manières si quelque chose ne vient
pas ça veut dire que je dois continuer
avec ça donc ça veut dire qu'il vous
porte pendant un certain monsieur quoi
alors on va vous écouter vous avez
vraiment nous faire un grand plaisir je
vais vous demander de rejoindre tout
votre groupe et vous allez nous
interpréter en direct sur le plateau un
extrait de cet album le morceau
s'intitule marley comme bob marley bien
sûr
polka de magis musique en malaisie
wallonie
no cry center archifaux you might
verraszto mains du moins ce qu'il écoute
mon steak sous droits give the world
qu'est ce thème sous droit pour qui le
sport de masse
politiquement la musique de paris n'est
pas bien inspiré du plessis l'ostal
mêmes
mais les appliquer
continuer est visible au moins 30 dans
le bourg serait guère d'ici selon
talibans du pakistan ttp
oui il faut les voir une garde en salle
béziers de la stam un hymne aux autres
ils écoutent main qui pousse ou d'euros
n'oublie leur baptême sur tout témoin
tout comme ma famille dit doucet inbev
partance ici par oui non mais dites moi
mon tube all thing digital lebrija long
mano kaiser rafiq al mabhouh
désir de recevoir youssou n'dour dans
c'est un petit peu un aperçu du concert
qui aura lieu ce soir à l'olympia
malheureusement c'est complet si vous
n'avez pas de place mais il ya encore
une autre date c'est le 19 juin pour le
grand bal africain à bercy et puis ne
ratez surtout pas cet album qui est
magnifique et qui s'appelle bakar
kingston c'est chez universal merci
vraiment encore à youssou ndour d'être
venu en direct sur ce plateau
dans quelques minutes vous pourrez
retrouver les questions supplémentaires
que vous avez posées à notre invité sur
notre site internet france 2 point fr
vous pourrez aussi poser d'autres
questions à notre invité de demain
recevront michel du chose